bindi Irwin goes snorkeling in the
middle of winter in Australia Steve
Irwin 17 year old daughter bindi didn't
let the cool weather stop her from
getting into the ocean and close to
nature on Thursday she posted a photo on
Instagram in a wetsuit snorkel gear in
hand writing soaking up the sunlight and
swimming with turtles and manta rays
doesn't get much better than this
hashtag Australian winter done right and
the Dancing with the Stars champ let
everyone know her adventure was truly
perfection posting a video flying over
her native Australia calling it hashtag
forever home while Aaron's boyfriend
wakeboarding champ Chandler Powell
seemed to be missing his lady on her
snorkeling adventure he posted a
throwback pic of the two on a beach
writing
can't wait to see what we get into next
safe to say bindi can't wait either
she guessed ooh et in June about her bow
no matter what is happening he's he's
always there for me and he always makes
me smile and laugh and it's brilliant to
have someone so kind who really
understands your world